[Applause]
okay so um you're planning to build up
an app which is okay hopefully are
connected okay so um they're planning to
build an app it's a slash up in slack
using Google Cloud functions so I want
to build something so what is a slash
app right so it's something like you
give a slash and then you give like a
small command and then give some text to
it
and then you try to get some output so
for example I say clash kg / London
hopefully it works it takes a bit of
time to watch
oh yeah so okay so this is so this is
what we are trying to build okay
so initially I was thinking of writing
the code live but yeah it's only five
minutes so it might be difficult I don't
want to experiment here so so so this is
this is kind of like the architecture
that we are going to follow so you're
the person here the slack here and
you're passing this message and then
there is a cloud function which executes
which takes this message does some kind
of like processing and then gives the
result back okay so the processing
happens like it's basically we're making
an API call to Google Google knowledge
graph API okay so um and then we feed it
back to the user so there are only two
things here so we are dealing with slack
and we are dealing with cloud functions
and knowledge graph API so slack has us
like a certain format in which the
message has to be sent and the message
has to be received and similarly the
knowledge graph API we have to make the
query in certain way and it returns the
result in a certain format okay so let's
go and look at the code so the code is
available here in the Google cloud
Python doc samples so we have functions
here
and then there is slack here okay and
then there is this card this is the card
okay so before we do anything so we will
need two things so one is like a slack
token to talk to slack and then we will
need a Search API token for the Google
knowledge graph API okay so let's go to
slack let's get the token so let me
create a completely new workspace so say
you create a new workspace
okay let's say slack test
okay so that is the slug test here okay
and then let me I mean meanwhile go to
only four minutes left okay okay then
I'll start explaining the code then let
me not die yeah I already have the app
so so let's not worry about that okay so
let's look at the code so I've already
deployed the code just for backup
purpose so this is the code that is
running okay
so okay let me see it well okay so the
code is very simple that's that that's
the main point that I want to convey
here like in in cloud functions you can
write very simple functions and you get
the results very quickly and it hosts
like a web server for you okay so if you
look at the code here it's this is the
main call that we are making we have to
the to the Google Search API okay so we
are giving like a post request to the
Search API and we get like a JSON
response back okay so this is the search
request that is being made and we limit
the results to one and then we are
executing the query okay so the rest of
the code is basically just formatting
for the slack message so while we are
sending the message to slack we need to
give these three parameters okay so so
one is like attributes so one is the
response type which is in channel and
then we are giving what is the query so
if you look at it we have the query here
so the query and then you you you are
passing the rest of the rest of the
information as attachments okay so that
is the format that slack is expecting
okay and these are all the fields that
we are passing text title link title
image URL so these are all the
information that we are passing back
okay one moment it clicked okay fine so
um so this is only code okay and then we
have the config dot JSON which is where
you are passing the keys passing the
like the tokens okay and then
it's all it's all temporary I'll delete
it so don't worry about it
so these are the libraries that you need
to pass it okay so that's it that's it
here and then if you look at the slack
command this is the last thing that I'm
going to say hopefully I can modify this
okay hopefully I can get this so this is
basically just the URL which I'm which
I'm passing okay
so maybe I don't have it here so I can
look at it here as well so trigger I
just need to look at the trigger so the
trigger gives me the URL so the web
server is hosted here basically okay so
you can it's very easy to build it
doesn't take more than like 10 minutes
to build like a complete up
[Applause]